hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play paso de la
posada hello hey say hello you guys have
been suggesting this one for a while
food is only I was talking about work
the next day after all the stories I'd
heard about that place
about evil creatures deaths and missing
people I can't stop thinking about how
this place really is like if there is
any truth to all those stories of course
not
it is ghost stories when people die
that's is good enough justification to
go wandering right into the place where
everyone's dying hello Oh
birdy Skylar's presents I like this is
creative Ames Einar Josquin ha sido ha
care for now sees name's Stefano a glove
with a ski Robert o que con oh my
goodness oh don't get in don't get in
what don't get in that door I don't
think you can get in the door but anyway
oh I have a choice here ok going cuz I'm
stupid hey let's see what's up in store
don't know why the mouse is still in
there don't know if you guys can see
that again but whatever I'll try to ok
view walk jump interact and pause the
game ok
oh good my mouse one way turn the
generator on to light up the station why
am I in here in the first place what
kind of idiot wandered ass grit done
questioning ok generator
hey look it's some telly tubby pudding
telly tubby custard those in ok man I
was in a hurry before I don't know why
I'm so slow now I can't even sprint what
is it what da one valve is missing Oh
ah gimme ah spare valve in the
administrative room thank you kind run
away from what Minnie key why well okay
administrative over this way this has
made in the Unity engine so obviously
it's graphics are quite good as you know
baseline compared to other indie horror
games I'm actually kind of impressed
with the atmosphere so far it seems very
dark I like the music administration hi
shut up [ __ ] get out here who do you
think you are
let's see well I have a key
please stupid [ __ ] are locked I
don't know what this what horror mythos
this is don't let see you don't let what
see me oh yeah the bathrooms great idea
me yeah what kind of toilets are these
alright whatever whatever don't that's
an awfully mysterious lighting fixture
hmm how suspicious okay my mouse is
going all over the place guys bye I see
it in the background it's just not in
the game I hope I hope when I click it
doesn't like totally throw me off I
don't think I need to click I think it's
just e okay so I can't go in there I
need to go towards this Teletubby
custard see oh it's a train and I
thought because station is this hang on
what is this it's a key
aha well nothing suspicious here
jump ELISA can jump that's good
mobility is important when you're
struggling to run away from a giant
diabolical monster
kliklak ah [ __ ] was that
this [ __ ] generator 4 2 1 3 okay it just
went right through the walls at them
team right 4 2 1 3
good call a duty love me some card dude
sickly 360noscope think it's a god
I don't know what that was I mean it
seemed weird that it just kind of went
bright through one wall wound into
another that's not bode well for my
survival just saying
spare valves right here okay 4 2 1 3
I'm doing her haha okay is there any aha
why do I need to run why do I need to
run what goes here
what why do you keep pointing me in
different directions that I don't want
to see why can I suddenly now run is
that gonna explode why why I have so
many questions
can I get enough back out
well yeah don't look at it don't look at
your dumb man holy balls
I need the screwdriver for something Oh
aah aah
seven minutes no no I'm sorry what did i
do what did I just pick up I pick up
something okay I think I know where that
that light bulb goes it's not safe out
there no joke
jeez okay I got to go back to the
bathroom I got this light bulb that I'm
gonna stick in the thingy good god
I'm trying good luck no is there some
secret message on the walls yes two
three three one bingo
two three
hey uh I got a door panel code majiggy
thingy see fine for master keys Raj oh
here we go
I just forgotten what it was two three
three one two three three one I think it
was don't look back
I've tried it oh here we go come on two
three three one enter
I go [ __ ] I got master keys restroom
key oh good god
stop that oh don't like you what's in
here
what do I need why are you many keys
find two more mini keys ha ha stop
jain's us good god stop it I hate you
ok another mini key I need oh they're so
tiny
there's no way I'm gonna find them all
I've obviously missed one
where's the other one oh I gotta look
everywhere again you [ __ ] this [ __ ] this
place I'm not gonna make it I got 5
minutes
oh Jesus oh oh why do I have so many
damn keys and nothing to use them on I
gotta go back in maybe oh maybe on like
one of the benches or something in here
I missed it somehow tiny itty-bitty key
somewhere
oh god get away oh man ah [ __ ] ow
I know kung foo in here maybe oh [ __ ] ah
ah where's another damn it Kate hey you
stop that
got that right now maybe on the ground
in the middle here ah gah never
yeah I am Wow hi well okay he's not he
doesn't seem to be like an actual threat
I don't know right what about in here
what about this door here locked in any
key in here I already got the one in
here right she's gonna overheat
cuz I'm an [ __ ] to myself about this
in the administrative room maybe I I was
locked there are a lot of locked doors
here I have a lot of keys that don't do
[ __ ] cap now where's the dick I've gotta
be some there's gotta be he's got oh
come on what if I had forgotten the code
what if you're an [ __ ] well wait a
min you're already uh ha oh that's a
master key oh okay that's helpful
come on it's gotta be here it's gotta be
yeah come on got it got it got it moving
yeah I'm gonna make it oh good golly Oh
screw you goo you through you and
everything you care about gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme a chav a mister
what does that mean is that the master
key I don't care I'm getting out of here
aha
rush I win
ha I won good God Jesus Maloney ha ha ha
oh man I don't think I've ever been
screaming that much for so long oh maybe
I know man ah oh man I don't know if
that monster was actually a threat or
anything I couldn't tell jeez
he was just there ah did not like him
kind of reminded me of a mixture between
SCP um oh nine 600 92 or I forget the
one the worry if you look at his face
comes after you the kind of model same
model and also the model that they used
in the rake you know in those games I
played me a good job Scylla's ha ha ha
oh man that's good
that was like my heart was pounding
for I really wish those away like I
could hook up like a heart where a heart
meter when I'm when I'm playing these
games that I could have it up in the
corner like ma ma ma ma ma ma ma ma ma
but that'd just be way too much work
anyway great job Scylla's forget your
real name but thank you so much it's
like some martinis or something I can't
remember but anyway great game click the
annotation or click are clicking the
description below for the link to the
game itself click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
wait hang on let me see if there's
something else nope nope that's it so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you the next video
bye
don't even try to